bonjour à tous un petit tutoriel qui
vous est proposé ici pour savoir comment
utiliser la classe alors en place on
utilise généralement le grand atlas de
chez de boucler la maison d'édition ce
qui est toujours intéressant c'est quand
vous utilisez un atlas de savoir de
quelle édition il s'agit ici vous voyez
bien que c'est la dernière édition la
14e qui date de 2014 dont tout le monde
n'a pas la même édition en place peut
être que vous en avez donc alors si je
prends des autres à classe voyez ici
c'est toute vieille édition c'est quand
j'étais moi même à l'école je l'avais
hérité de ma cousine
oui ici on est en 1984 donc il a
évidemment entre 1984 et 2004
j'ai eu beaucoup d'eau a coulé sous les
ponts et à une question aussi
d'actualisation de la classe il faut
avoir donc c'est toujours intéressant de
savoir quand a été fait votre place
juste à côté de cette première page
belge et un avant propos qui est en fait
le mode d'emploi de la classe donc tout
ce que je vous dis ici dans le tutorial
vous avez ça qui est retranscrit ici
c'est à la page suivante on arrive
directement la table des matières qui
est une table des matières thématiques
où l'ensemble des cartes de la place
sont proposés ici c'est assez facile
parce que voyez un code couleur donc la
belgique ce sont les cartes vers
l'europe
les cartes jaunes et ainsi de suite et
que vous avez sur les transats là si je
prends des cartes qui sont avec une
tranche jaune là j'arrive sur des cartes
de l'europe
donc ça c'est déjà très facile alors si
vous montrez dans le détail vous allez
voir que c'est un indice à l'index par
dont une table de matières thématiques
dont ici j'ai toute une série de cartes
n'y a pas que la carte avec des routes
et des montagnes la plaine chose par
exemple si je veux la terre un petit peu
sur la question de l'énergie mais je
dois me rendre à la page 2 107 alors on
ne parlera pas de page en terme d'art
ici dans la classe on parlera de
planches je vais à la clenche 207 et à
la planche 207
je retrouve bien la terre toutes les
cartes thématiques qui concerne
l'énergie alors par exemple si vous
voyez vous à la production de gaz
naturel
la production de charbon et ainsi de
suite
donc première outils pour utiliser la
placette cartes thématiques pour les
deux autres outils je dois me rendre à
la fin de la place à la toute dernière
page voyez que directement entré ya plus
de deux pages c'est la couverture j'ai
ce qu'on appelle l'index des cartes
alors là j'ai directement une
représentation du monde qui me permet de
localiser directement les cartes je veux
par exemple si je veux une carte de
france ben voilà la france 1
ben voila je dois me rendre à la page 68
69 alors dit pas page
on dit bien sûr planches 68 69
je trouve bien une carte de france ici
la carte oro hydrographique
ça c'est pour le deuxième outil un outil
donc très visuel mais pour utiliser cet
outil il faut déjà savoir avoir quelques
repères géographiques
si on a vraiment aucun repère par
exemple si je vous dis ou situe la ville
de manaus
vous savez sans doute pas où se situe
peut-être que les plus les plus démunis
d'entre vous le sauront mais c'est pas
grave de ne pas savoir ce qui est grave
c'est de ne pas savoir utiliser la
classe alors c'est très simple je vais
aller dans cet index qui est un index
alphabétique ou en fait tout est rangé
par ordre alphabétique comme dans un
dictionnaire
alors je vais chercher manaus je vais
bien sûr dans les aime et je le trouve
ici vous voyez manaus et on me dit que
ça se trouve à la planche 161 d3e 361
pas de problème il ya peut-être ces
lettres qui vont perturber les roues
l'autre mais c'est très facile c'est un
peu comment la bataille navale
vous avez en eau voyez les coordonnées b
c d e f est ici dans la marge
1 2 3 donc j'ai bien une carte
d'amérique du sud avec le brésil
mme dao se situe bien au brésil et on me
dit des 3 3 je vais prendre le ici le
carré qui est dans la bonne ranger est
dans la bonne colonne je suis dans la
colonne des jeux descend jusque dans la
rangée
détroit 2 3 manaus je crois que c'est un
peu un jeu d'enfant de cette manière de
retrouver une localisation donc avec cet
outil
même si on n'a pas de connexion internet
mais je peux me débrouiller pour
retrouver tous les lieux dont on parlera
au cours de géographie
je reste à votre disposition si vous
avez des questions et à bientôt